One of the best things about the home
releases of Marvel movies is that they
almost always come with a gag reel.
Here's some examples of Marvel movie
bloopers we think might even be
better than the original scenes.
In 2004's Spider-Man 2, Peter Parker
isn't finding young adulthood easy.
He may have super powers and genius level
intellect, but the challenge of juggling college,
multiple jobs, a social life, and fighting
crime as Spider-Man is proving too much for him.
In one of the many scenes meant to show how Parker
is struggling, he drops his textbooks and as he
kneels down to retrieve them, multiple passing
students whack him in the head with their bags.
The movie's gag reel shows us one take
when things went even worse for Parker,
although thankfully Maguire has a good sense
of humor about it. Shortly after Parker is hit
from behind by one student's bag, he's hit by
another from the front. A prompt shows us the
second student is none other than the director
of the first Spider-Man film trilogy, Sam Raimi.
Although the extended battering of Peter would
have definitely made the finished scene funnier,
perhaps Raimi decided that choking his lead
actor with a backpack was going a little too far.
On the Avengers gag reel, Mark Ruffalo
proves himself to either have a
wealth of underutilized slapstick
comedy potential or to simply be
the clumsiest actor on just about any
superhero movie set you could find.
In the middle of filming one of his
lab scenes with Robert Downey, Jr.,
Ruffalo calls for the crew to wait while he resets
a prop -- which proves easier said than done.
"Careful, actor on set."
"Sorry. I got it, don't worry!"
It's okay, it's coming!"
While this clumsiness actually would have
worked well for Bruce Banner's character,
it may have been a little too silly for
the high-stakes world of the Avengers.
"Dudes, you're on your own!"
In what the Avengers' Blu-ray calls
"Marvel's First Ever Gag Reel," it's
clear that director Joss Whedon's trademark
sense of humor infected the entire cast.
"Stop fighting!"
But Whedon's not the only one who gets to make
you laugh. As S.H.I.E.L.D. agent Maria Hill, Cobie
Smulders doesn't get to flex her comedy muscles in
the MCU as often she did on How I Met Your Mother.
However, she makes up for it with what's arguably
the funniest moment in the Avengers bloopers.
Pretending to react to the
news of Phil Coulson's death,
Smulders has what we'll call, a dramatic reaction.
"Coulson, no! Oh, God, you were
the greatest man I ever knew..."
We can't, in good conscience, pretend Maria
Hill's over-the-top meltdown would have fit
into the actual movie. But there's no
denying it would have been hilarious.
The first time Captain America, Iron Man, and
Thor meet in The Avengers, things don't go that
well. The thunder god kidnaps Loki from the
Quinjet, prompting Iron Man to fly after him.
Intending to follow him, Cap grabs a
parachute and jumps out of the plane.
But in the gag reel, things
went a little differently.
On the reel, Chris Evans still
grabs the parachute, but has
absolutely no idea how to get the thing
on. He struggles with it for so long that
it gets to the point where you start
to genuinely feel bad for the guy.
"Guess it doesn't go up as
smoothly as I was hoping."
While it would've taken away from the intensity of
the scene, showing this in the finished film might
actually have made sense for the character. After
all, the last time Steve Rogers used a parachute
was decades earlier, and the design could have
significantly changed since World War II. Seeing
Steve struggle with his modern parachute could've
been yet another amusing reminder that although
you can take the Captain out of the 1940s,
you can't take the 1940s out of the Captain.
In one of the funnier moments of 2014's Guardians
of the Galaxy, Michael Rooker's Yondu chooses a
unique intimidation tactic. While the Broker
tries to explain why he can't give Yondu the
information he wants, Yondu keeps interrupting him
with gibberish. While this is already humorous in
the movie, in the gag reel, it ventures into the
realm of the absurd, as Rooker just keeps going.
[gibberish]
“The high end-”
[gibberish continues]
“Sir!”
[gibberish continues again]
Behind him, you can even see co-star Sean
Gunn trying hard not to laugh in a few takes.
Sure, we think the finished scene is funny enough,
but adding in Rooker's extended gibberish
monologue would have taken it to the next level.
Sylvester Stallone and Kurt Russell have a
few things in common. They both hit their fame
sweet spots in the 1980s, they both appear
in 2017's Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2,
and both get frustrated on the sequel's gag reel
trying to spit out Guardians-specific names.
The gag reel shows that while
playing the Ravager leader Stakar
"Ravager.”
“Ravengers."
"Ravager. What am I saying?"
"Ravenger."
"No!"
"Ravager."
"Yes!"
"Ah, forget it, I'll see you in looping."
Meanwhile, Kurt Russell has
trouble saying his son's codename.
As he camps with the Guardians, Russell says,
"Well, even where I reside, out
past the edge of what's known,
we've heard tell about the
man they call Star Wars."
Of course, we all know the
name he really means to say is
"Star Lord."
"Who?”
"Star-Lord, man. Legendary outlaw?"
Russell immediately realizes his mistake, and
eventually manages to get his son's name right.
However, leaving in the actors' mistakes could
have added a bit to the respective scenes.
Showing Stakar pronouncing "Ravagers" differently
than Yondu could have highlighted the division
between the two of them. And the fact that
Ego keeps getting his kid's name mixed up
with that of a popular Earth movie franchise
could underscore what a horrible father he is.
"Well of course I have issues.
That's my freaking father."
The scenes set in the dystopian future
of 2014's X-Men: Days of Future Past have
a pretty bleak tone, so it almost feels
wrong that the movie even has a gag reel.
But it's good that it does, since
the outtakes are pretty hilarious.
Among other funny bits, the gag reel includes a
ridiculous alternate version of a deleted scene.
Before time traveling to the past
to prevent the dystopian future in
which the Sentinels have hunted mutants to
near extinction, Wolverine turns to Storm.
After confirming that he'll be the only
one to remember this version of the future,
he gives his teammate a long kiss. Although
the scene is likely supposed to end there,
Halle Berry follows it up with an
unexpected reaction in the gag reel.
"Yes! That kiss!"
Although Berry's response to the kiss would
have broken the bleak mood, the kiss itself
may have been a nice addition to the finished
film. On the other hand, sharing a kiss with
Storm earlier in the film might have made seeing
her right before Wolverine's emotional reunion
with the previously deceased Jean Grey at
the end of the film slightly more awkward.
As far as MCU movies go, 2016's Captain
America: Civil War is pretty intense.
The final throwdown between
the warring heroes gets ugly,
but thankfully one of the architects of
Marvel Comics shows up toward the end to
not only deliver an important package to Tony
Stark, but to make sure we get in a few laughs.
In one of his many beloved Marvel cameos,
the late Stan Lee shows up to the Avengers'
headquarters as a FedEx driver, delivering
the package that contains a letter from
Steve Rogers along with an emergency
contact phone. In the finished product,
Lee accidentally misreads the name of
the recipient, much to Rhodey's delight.
"Are you Tony Stank?"
"Yes, this is Tony Stank. You're in
the right place. Thank you for that."
However, the film's gag reel shows a
take where Lee says something else,
and we're not sure if he did it on
purpose or if it was a legitimate goof.
"Are you Robert Stank?"
While the original scene was hilarious, fusing
the mispronunciation of the character's last
name with the actor's real-life first name
could've been a fun fourth-wall-breaking
moment. It even would have made an odd sort of
sense, considering that Marvel has officially
canonized the popular fan theory that Lee
is playing a Watcher in all of his cameos.
The blooper reel on the home release for
2016's Deadpool makes it clear that several
of the actors frequently veered off-script.
Deadpool's gag reel includes a wealth of
completely improvised lines, particularly from
Ryan Reynolds and his co-star, T.J. Miller.
For example, when Miller's Weasel first sees Wade
Wilson's scarred face, the comedian unleashes a
torrent of improvised takedowns, expressing
his disgust at his friend's new appearance.
"You look like somebody turned your face
inside out and just left it like that,
but then you got in a house fire. God, you look
like a house fire was in another house fire."
Meanwhile, Reynolds' own improv includes a long
list of jabs toward Gina Carano's Angel Dust.
"Gonna leave me all alone here with Busta Rhymes?”
“You're gonna leave me all
alone here with Henry Winkler?”
“Gonna leave me all alone here with HEY YOU GUYS?"
Hilariously, the reel shows that the line
that made it into the theatrical release
ticked Carano off so much she gave Reynolds
an actual punch to the face as a reward.
"Sorry, Gina."
"Mother[bleep]"
While it's true that putting all of Miller's
and Reynolds' improvised outtakes into the
finished film probably wouldn't have worked
from a pacing perspective, we wouldn't have
minded giving each of them an opportunity to riff
just a little bit longer in each of these scenes.
One of the most delightful parts of 2018's
Deadpool 2 is Wade Wilson's corrective time
romp during the mid-credits scenes. Deadpool
uses Cable's repaired time travel device to save
his girlfriend and his X-Force teammate Peter,
prevent the making of the 2011 film Green Lantern,
and cut short the action of
2009's X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
But while Negasonic Teenage Warhead has a
surprisingly easy time fixing the device,
Deadpool has a tough time grabbing ahold
of it. On the gag reel we learn that it
took Ryan Reynolds at least four takes
to catch the device without dropping it.
Considering how ridiculous the Deadpool
films tend to be, we can't help but wonder
if the main character repeatedly fumbling the
time travel device might have actually played
well in the film. Maybe Wade could have even
capped the moment with his signature slogan.
"Maximum effort."
There's one little wonderful nugget about the
making of the Star Wars prequels that fans
of the franchise love, even if they aren't
particularly fond of the films themselves.
According to Ewan McGregor, the Obi-Wan Kenobi
actor would regularly make the lightsaber
sound effects with his mouth during fight scenes.
"To begin with, it was quite difficult
not to make the sound. Bzzz. And also
when it goes away, because it makes that
nice shhhhk noise when it goes down."
Well, according to the gag reel
for 2017's Thor: Ragnarok, McGregor
isn't alone in accidentally trying
to do the sound team's job for them.
Cate Blanchett plays the death
goddess Hela in Ragnarok,
and the gag reel includes a few takes
of different scenes in which Blanchett
makes childlike sound effects to accompany
the unleashing of her character's powers.
[Blanchett making noises]
"I shouldn't make the noises
with my mouth, should I?"
The gag reel also reveals that Blanchett's
fight scenes with co-star Chris Hemsworth
offered other challenges. The Oscar-winning
actress had a tough time dragging her co-star
across the floor, as well as finding
it tough to not hit Hemsworth for real.
"Sorry guys, I've been training for
months, but I don't think I can lift that."
Sure, maybe Hela wouldn't have been
quite as intimidating if she was making
her own sound effects and fumbling her
fights with her superpowered siblings,
but in a film filled with plenty
of other visual and audible gags,
including Blanchett's goofs may not
have felt entirely out of place.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your
favorite Marvel films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.